you're what is up everybody mad Luigi
here with another no man's sky video and
if you've been thinking about getting no
man's sky or you're on the fence or
you're just interested in no man's sky
and you haven't heard about the giant
day one update Lynn let me tell you
something alright so day one is going to
be a huge 800 megabyte update for no
man's sky the size of a no man's sky is
six gigabytes update eight hundred
megabytes large update very very large
update if you're confused why the game
is so small it's because of a magic code
that's why all right so I'm gonna run
down some of these things that are going
to be in this update that you guys need
to get hype for all right they're adding
three unique paths you can follow
through wrap the game that significantly
impact what you see later on the game
they're making galaxies up to ten times
bigger they're making more hazardous
planets with deadlines they're making a
better more intense atmospheric system
they're adjusting planet rotation
they're adding wider ship diversity
they're adding a deeper trading system
they're adding larger inventory slots
threading their own feeding system to
animals that can poop how valuable
resources there are any more hazardous
survival they balanced a bunch of stuff
they made combatant space combat better
they fixed exports that people were
using in the leaks they've improved
stability they made more varied space
stations they increase the networking
that made better ship scanning and made
flying over terrain look better and they
made the writing of the Atlas better
than the Atlas is the most mysterious
crazy thing that's gonna be going on in
this game maybe also later on they're
working on the ability to build bases
and other giant space freighters but
that that's the next update if that all
doesn't get you hyped up and roll over a
lot of the qualms from the leaks then I
don't think anything will so I've been
working on this update for about a month
since the game won gold till around now
which is released and they're putting a
lot of stuff that's definitely going to
polish up the game a lot better
obviously we can't know until we play
the game until the game comes out for
ps4 and PC on the nine ten to the
twelfth respectively I'm really salty
about it coming out on the 12 / p 6 i'm
getting it for pc and that's three days
and i'm crying and yeah if you want to
see more no man's sky content continue
to check out my channel since i'll be
posting a lot more of it since the
game is getting me hyped and I'll let
you be letting us know if you should get
it all right thank you for watching get
hyped I'm hyped you should be hyped
peace out